Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Connors. Again, we're going to talk of this video about skin cancers
Skin cancers are very near and dear to my heart my wife had melanoma
Betty family members with either melanoma or basal cell carcinoma
But it's probably pretty near and dear to a lot of people's heart basal cell carcinoma is
Extremely common, especially as we age
You see that a lot of times with people on their head and neck and face
It's very common melanoma is becoming more and more common and basal cell carcinoma is also
Pretty common. So if you're listening to this you probably have fed yourself or friends or family members and are dealing with it
So please look on our site on how to deal with it because it can this is something that can be
taken care of with alternative care very very successfully. So
Look into adding alternative care to your
Protocol even if you're doing standards of care
It could be very confusing understating your diagnosis. We realize that
Extra-membrace page disease. I put it in here
Usually that's that diagnosed till it's
metastasized
To the colon or the rectal area or the bladder
But it really is a skin cancer. It's very rare
But that's very dear to my heart because that's what I have so it
The skin cancers are important cancers is because they can become very serious. Especially extra-membrace page disease and a little
When you go to the doctor, you get a diagnosis with any type of cancer
You're gonna be inundated with you know pushing being pushed down that medical road
And I'm not saying that it's wrong to go down the medical road
But you do not have to choose between standards of care and alternative care. So it's something that can be done
Concurrently so
Looking to adding alternative care shouldn't be called alternative care to be something that we do on a regular basis anyhow
These natural things that can keep our body healthy could stimulate our immune system and take care of us
But what do we do decide to add alternative care? It gets confusing and I understand that
What pills should I take what supplements should I take mushrooms or protocell?
I just don't know everybody's given me these things and giving me advice. I read it on the web on the
On the internet to start on Facebook whatever. That's what we're here to do is to bring some clarification
To your life. We test you specifically to find out what are gonna be your best
Cancer balancers what is gonna be your best diet to go with what are we gonna do to cut off the fuel source
What are gonna be the best frequencies for gonna use rife technology with you?
So the more specific that you could be
To your cancer and your situation the better success you're gonna have and ultimately
That's what we want is to you to have success in your journey here
So we just want to come along
Side you and partner with you and be your coach with that. So
Whether you choose us or not utilize our site download by books
And no regardless we will be pray for you. Thanks so much